the dispossession is part of it but you
know there's this really fascinating
study out of india about
um political violence and so what
happened the number one thing for
political violence in india is when they
they did it with the visa with with
expenditure records so as muslims the
marginalized group get more money to
spend compared to hindus that's when the
violence starts right and the the and
they this can be so everywhere
well exactly because like what's
actually happening is in america you
have you know black people and and
latino people moving up
and you have economically politically
america's about to become a majority
minority country by 2040 and as that
happens the the over class essentially
reacts with violence and you can see
that everywhere you can see that in
india you can see it all over africa you
can see it in asia you can see it in the
middle east certainly so
you know that that is to me if you're
asking what the deeper process is
underway the psychological process
that that would be right at the top of
the list in fact when they there's an
amazing study that came out about the
january 6 insurrectionists and they own
like
only a very about 20 of them were from
the militias but the the huge
overwhelming factor was that they all
came from counties where exactly that
thing had happened where exactly that
phenomenon i saw that where they came
from counties that had been becoming
more diverse uh relatively recently and
you know it's amazing because it's not
them becoming poorer right
it's like it's not like it's not like
them becoming it's not them losing it's
the people below them gaining in
relation to them that they that causes
the violence which is even worse i mean
like what is even darker
[Music]
this week on the forward podcast the
author of the next civil war steven
marsh joins me with his vision of what's
to come in the us is a breakup
inevitable this week on forward
[Music]
it is my pleasure to welcome to the
forward podcast author of the next civil
war which i have in my hot little hands
steven marsh welcome stephen hi andrew
pleasure to be here
now it's great to have you
so first what the heck prompted you to
write this very very dramatic book which
i enjoyed a great deal
uh and two how has the reception been
since you've been out there touring and
promoting
well the reception's been great i'll
answer your second question first the
reception's been great i mean it's been
a bit odd because i've sort of been on
all kinds of media like left-wing media
right-wing media and
they have such they're so different and
they have such different takes on this
stuff and i mean sometimes it's like it
really is like coming from canada it's
sort of like like at one point one of
the the right-wing groups asked me like
would a civil war even be that bad a
thing and i was like uh yeah you know
like south carolina lost 25 percent of
its male population
like 2.5 percent of the american
population died in the first civil war
civil wars the world the worst thing
that can happen to a country i think
it's probably worse you're you're not
praising the possibility of a civil war
okay it never occurred to me i mean it
literally never occurred to me that
someone would suggest that a civil war
might be a good thing um but you know so
uh
i wrote the book as a warning right
about what about how dangerous civil
wars are and how close the united states
was and i mean the real inspiration for
it was i was at i was i was sent by a
canadian magazine to cover the trump
inauguration what the heck did canadians
think is going on with us
they were like you have to you have to
go go tell us what's going on you know
i'm standing on top of a limousine at
one point and then the limousine was lit
on fire there was also like people
handing out joints but then it was that
patchwork washington
like it's illegal on federal land so
it's like don't you know here the joints
are free over there you could go to jail
for them like it was there was quite a
lot of chaos and then in the middle of
the night like two three in the morning
a fellow journalist from canada called
me and said we're going to a party
and uh i said okay
if he told me to i was going to it was
in georgetown and it was like a
low-level guy at the usda
and you know the kind of guy who's
responsible for wheat in 2050 or
whatever the you know the bureaucrats
that keep us all alive and he'd taken
all the presidential photos with him and
he was and he'd taken his chair from the
office and i said you know what what's
going on he said no one came to replace
me today like we turned off the lights
at the u.s the u.s department of
agriculture today and i was like okay
this is this is very serious like uh
it's time to really go in deep over the
next like all other projects are going
to be put on hold we're just going to
look at what what is going wrong in
america and how badly it's going wrong
and the book is really the answer to
that question which is you know
unfortunately pretty bad so this was a
political appointee who just went home
and everyone uh just shrugged well
ordinarily like you know if ordinarily
for every other president that's ever
been elected in history that team would
have been established two years ago
right like they would have known who
would have taken that job like a million
years earlier right and somebody would
have come and taken over their papers
and that would have been it and
like unlike you know canada or britain
or other parliamentary democracies where
there's a really stable civil service
that in effect runs the country and the
politicians kind of come and try and
move that ship around a bit like it was
like there's no one there
right and that that really and you know
of course like that became really clear
during the trump years with the with the
state department especially where i
think in the end only about a third of
positions were ever even filled yeah
they were trying to starve the state
department for whatever reason it was a
very odd
approach to diplomacy so this is january
2017 right the inauguration
that's right yeah and so you write the
article about the inauguration and you
go back to your editors or you know or
whomever and say hey guys i think the us
is heading towards
deep [ __ ] approaching and i want to
write uh did it start out as a book was
it articles like what was the next it
was an article it was an article um and
they said uh gee i said i want to write
about this i think of civil wars well
i'd actually went i did some research
first like i went to a gun show in tulsa
and then i went to ohio for the guardian
and hung out with some oath keepers and
i was interviewing nazis and i was
interviewing far-right people hard right
people and you know just meeting them
and like trying to get a feel from the
ground of what this is like you know
what what the reality is here were they
welcoming to the canadian journalists
were they into it or did you feel if you
look like me they're if you look like me
they're the sweetest guys in the world i
mean they're like there's it's
definitely uh you know like i i get
along very well with uh with white
supremacists and with uh with with with
hard right people they're they're
perfectly pleasant and i mean
that makes them much scarier right like
they're not these are not people with
born to lose tattooed on their chest
these are like
teachers and you know people who run
small businesses and like and and and
and they just happen to like walking
around armed and don't believe in the
validity of the federal authority right
and i think it's also like also they're
much more educated than i
would have believed like you know you go
and it's very scary when you go to talk
to someone and they're like and you're
like well how are you going to build
this white ethno state in the pacific
northwest and they're like oh well we'll
model it on japan's constitution and
they have a whole system for it and they
have law degrees and they know they know
what they're doing so that also scared
me and then i so then i did that sort of
ground grounding research and then i
really began to look into the models the
hyper partisanship models the
environmental models the uh you know the
research which is at a really high point
right now i mean i like i will say like
the the book one of the um
reasons you can write a book like this
is because the the modeling for a lot of
these things has gotten to the point
where it's just excellent because of the
quality of the data um and then i went
to my editors and said yeah i think the
civil war's coming i'd like to write
about and they said you've got to be out
of your mind yeah there's no way that's
going to happen
and i said really i think
they said you're being totally alarmist
i beg to differ editor like right
yeah i was like look i mean let me write
it and then we'll we'll go from there
um and then that that's what that's what
happened
[Music]
okay listen up 90 of the coffee from the
grocery store is actually stale so you
heard that right the coffee you know and
think you love needs an upgrade so
instead of re-buying the same old same
old let trade coffee send you something
freshly roasted that you're literally
guaranteed to love so here's the deal
trade sells the freshest roasted and
ethically sourced beans from america's
best independent roasters they ship to
you for free as often as you like whole
or ground however you like it so whether
you're a coffee nerd or you just want a
better daily cup trades real coffee
experts taste test over 400 roasts and
use tech to match you with your ideal
coffee based on your preferences and
brewing methods so for me you just take
this quick quiz whether you like it dark
or light or you like it in a k-cup or
like a ground and then they ship it to
you based on what you've matched with
and it's awesome so you can take this
quick
quiz and then trade coffee guarantees
you will love your first bag or they'll
replace it for free so they've been
featured in the press by wired and gq
and i've delivered over 5 million bags
of coffee like these guys are legit
there's no hassle you can skip your
shipments you can change your frequency
you cancel at any time
this stuff if you love coffee is a
better way to get awesome coffee and for
our listeners right now trade coffee is
offering a total of 20 off your first
three bags pretty great so that's if you
go to drinktrade.com
yang so to get started take their quiz
at drinktrade.com
yang and start your journey to the
perfect cup that's drinktrade.com
yang for 20 off your first three bags
check it out
among the
modeling and research that you dug into
was peter turchins model among them
where he has this political stress index
uh he's out of the university of
connecticut i believe and
uh it shows for him in their model which
includes a lot of different factors
including lack of opportunity for
educated elites
uh nutrition like a bunch of different
factors go into it but his study showed
political stress to be at literally
civil war levels which is one of the
reasons why i take this
uh possibility very seriously
well yeah i mean the fact that there's
like barbara walters books that uses a
completely separate methodology from
mine but comes to the exact same
conclusions i mean that's a bit of a
warning right like you could i i didn't
go through that model although i was
familiar with it i went through prio the
peace
research institute of oslo because i i
felt they had a sort of um
like a slightly more uh well i wouldn't
it would be fair to say more global but
like they they were they were not in
america right and part of the thing that
i wanted was to get like perspectives
outside of america on america because i
find like the debate in america is so
toxic that it kind of consumes like
everyone gets consumed within it um and
so yeah i mean he he that's an that's
excellent research though um but you
know the the
the models that i used um are more
specifically tied to inequality like and
though and those uh vertical inequality
and horizontal inequality both which are
you know literally at levels that the
republic has never seen before like
there's never been high higher
inequality back in back in 1776 there
was not this level of inequality
oh yeah we're in the new strange gilded
age uh uh supercharged by
uh technology uh and capitalism in
different ways so when you talk about a
horizontal inequality versus vertical
inequality explain i have a sense that
vertical inequality is the inequality
that most people think of
well inequality is like they're high
level there is there are some people who
are very rich and there are some people
are very poor um america of course is
the real extreme example of this
globally where uh you have you have like
i mean it's just it's off the charts
like it's the genie coefficient is just
so so crazy in the united states that it
basically breaks all the models a
horizontal inequality is inequality
between groups so inequality between
ethnic groups between different
identified between different regions uh
between different identifiable groups
and both are very high in the in the
united states um and both you know are
predictors of civil war i mean you know
like some people ask me what are the
most common things that lead into it um
you know the the anarchy is probably the
biggest one but i don't really like to
think of it that way because to me
uh the it's a complex cascading system
it's something where everything feeds
into
itself and that's why you get
such turbulence right like that's why
the unimaginable keeps happening all the
time like why it's like you just can't
believe something happened because
it it i think a lot of americans have
had that sense it's like oh that that
like i can't believe that's happening
but now it's almost commonplace
um so you just used a term enocracy uh
can you explain like societies that are
ripe for
civil war and for political violence
generally are not democracies or
um autocracies those are both very
stable like there's there's not going to
be a revolution in russia it's an
autocracy um there's not going to be a
revolution in canada god willing
although god knows we've come
close twice to losing the country in my
lifetime but uh and there was martial
law declared just before i was born but
um you know those those kind of
societies tend not to have lots of
political violence it's where you're in
this in between space the gray area like
the fake democracy the democracy that no
one has actual faith in exactly and
that i mean america is that now i think
and i agree it is yeah we very much
resemble a fake democracy for reasons
that you know like i'm i i'm very
animated about i i and i think like one
of the things about you is that the
rights always kind of made that argument
like the right has always sort of said
like they're not legitimate but now it's
people on the left and people with data
and people with not emotions but out of
reason saying uh you know this is not a
functioning
system anymore uh some of the reasons
why i think america has become a fake
democracy is that you have this
two-party system that is very rigidly
enforced
and now 83 to 90 of congressional races
are
gerrymandered to be safely blue or
safely red so that there's no real
uncertainty around which party is going
to emerge from that seat victorious to
the extent that any uncertainty exists
is in the primary
which ends up distorting incentives in
various ways but it does mean that if
you're in the minority party in 90 of
the country you might as well just not
vote or sit it out
and so when people go and exhort you to
be like oh get involved do this it's
like we've actually set it up so that
you can have no
meaningful impact on
this race but we're going to inflame you
we're going to make you mad in in
various ways
so that this
system i think is very very discouraging
to
uh
many many americans it's not a genuine
democracy in that if you did have
like an independent actor or party or
candidate the odds of them actually
being able to make headway are
vanishingly
low because you would need 10 million
dollars to run a statewide campaign like
what independent could have that uh you
know if you're an ordinary citizen
you're uh on the outside looking in so
you get told look you have to play
within these parties which by the way
again um you know like uh aren't really
open unto themselves you have this
strange media landscape that's hyper
polarized and uh gutted at the local
level so here's those so those are some
of the things i i think about when i
think fake democracy which is a
different argument than the stuff that
you've heard from let's say
uh the the right in times past
no that's true i mean
to me as an outsider like
the the
the inherent fairness of any electoral
system is kind of not really relevant
because what matters is that people feel
the system to be legitimate i mean
that's the basis of peaceful government
like like we have a first-past-the-post
system here which you know has it
definite you could like some sometimes
the majority party wins with 39 of the
vote right and everyone's you know sort
of outraged but then you know
this is just the system your system is
designed that way i mean how many
political yeah exactly active in canada
uh three well more there's at least four
actually but um
and you know sometimes one is like one
it's currently a minority government
with the third party being the king
maker really right now the ndp but my
point really is that
that's all fine and good until ordinary
people like you can survive all of that
until ordinary people start to feel that
their system is not representing the
popular will and i mean the evidence is
really becoming clear that that that is
that is happening that ordinary
americans don't feel that their
electoral system represents the popular
will and as you like for all the reasons
you just said that's a perfectly
rational uh point of view to hold right
and you know and the other thing is it's
only it's about to get much worse you
know like it's about to get much
dramatically worse
[Music]
so you embark on this journey in 2017
you're doing research and i had the same
experience twice actually when i wrote
my book the war on normal people i had a
thesis around the fact that automation
was going to transform the economy in
ways that were going to push many
americans to the side
and when i was doing that research it
was
much much more
uh garish and frightening than i had
ever imagined when i started the process
[Laughter]
i know it's funny isn't it where you're
like oh yeah well you're like well i
mean am i right and then you go and
you're like oh it's like as bad as it
looks on the surface it's much worse
underneath i mean for sure
yeah and your your book has a number of
snapshots from the future that feel
true to life uh that they feel like they
very well could happen or will happen
uh the the first of them i found to be
really
enthralling or fascinating is what you
call the battle of the bridge
uh and it did feel like it could be
ripped from the headlines uh can you
explain the fact pattern and the
research you did that led you to use
this as an example of a catalyst that
could send
the u.s towards some kind of
uh political violence
sure well there are a lot of
right-wing groups that
hate the federal government and they're
quite sizable but they're also quite
chaotic and they're ideologically
chaotic and they're organizationally
chaotic that doesn't mean they're weak
it means that there's just a huge
fragmented number of them and
they like sometimes and they go back and
forth between them so there's like q and
on people and then there's second uh
second amendment fundamentalists and
then there's tax uh you know people who
don't believe that they should pay any
tax and then there's sovereign citizens
and then there's sagebrush rebels which
about federal land so i had to i wanted
to imagine a scenario that would unite
them um like we saw in charlottesville
and the figure that seemed to me most
dangerous um was the the constitutional
sheriffs because they have authority um
they are elected um they are there's no
question that they're a democratic
representative and there's a large group
of them who really believe that in the
doctrine of interposition um even though
it's been roundly rejected by the
supreme court and every other court um
that the role of a
sheriff is to resist federal authority
um and they they kind of love this and
they
it's a big it's a big macho scene really
is what it is and so i just imagined the
the right coalescing around a sheriff
who suddenly decided to
uh not to resist the federal authority
and you know in that case the government
would have to respond there would be no
there would be it would not be a
question where it's like well what are
we gonna they would have to respond and
then you get into
you know military the military planning
for what they call full spectrum
operations in the homeland and the
extreme legal quagmire that would result
from trying to occupy
an american
county
and so the hypothetical you drew which i
thought was really smart
was that the feds want to shut down a
bridge
for repairs
and it would greatly inconvenience the
local community because they won't have
a bridge for a certain period of time so
the sheriff says screw that we're gonna
keep this bridge open and so the the
then you wind up with a bunch of
uh anti-government type saying freedom
keep the bridge open and the feds having
to play the heavies the bad guys being
like no we're gonna shut this bridge
down now the bridge could have
structural problems but it works today
so uh you know the so it's not like the
bridge is crumbling before everyone's
eyes and so for the average person on
the ground they're like why are you
shutting this bridge down
well yeah but i mean
like it is a bit like like like covet
right where you have like the experts
are on one side and p and and ordinary
people don't want to do it because it's
extremely annoying right um but like
there are a lot of bridges in america
that no one should be driving over a lot
and the infrastructure is at a
really staggeringly
i mean unacceptable point um but yeah
like i mean the reason i took a bridge
is because that exact thing happened in
the 80s in arizona and i just talked to
the guy who did it i mean with this book
i really tried to stay
like like
it's a work of imagination in a way like
i'm imagining these scenarios but i
literally made sure that everything
could be footnoted and that there was
there was a there was an analog to all
of it so that it you know it's it's this
is not about grounded in reality i am
either happy
to say
i i mean i worked like if there was an
example from history that i could take i
just took it right i didn't i didn't
mess around it's just like i will just
use what's there
and uh and
and and go from there because also the
other thing is you don't need to
frighten people
like you we don't you don't need to make
stuff up to be scary with this stuff
like you know like if you tell the basic
facts they're plenty scary enough
yeah i agree so let's play out the
scenario as you did in the book just so
people get have a sense of as to how
this might play out
um so you have a bunch of far-right
groups show up on the bridge saying yeah
like you know
free country defend the bridge the
sheriff's uh hero and the the the the
sheriff's doing
interviews on various uh radio shows uh
and
cable tv being lauded uh and then half
the country says this play this guy's a
kook this guy's uh you know not like
anti-law enforcement not actually law
enforcement this inner position thing is
garbage
uh and then eventually you have the u.s
military encircling this bridge saying
what are we going to do you have
hundreds of activists on the bridge
partying all night you have most
reasonable americans looking at this
saying well i certainly don't agree with
what the heck is going on in that bridge
but i don't know if i agree with
shooting and killing the people on the
bridge um though the people on the
bridge are in this case heavily armed
with uh you know automatic weapons and
the rest of it um and so that's the
scenario you draw out and if you're most
americans you think well what you'd want
would be a peaceful resolution of this
standoff but if a peaceful resolution is
not in the offing
and
bloodshed does take place you can very
easily imagine
uh the sheriff and others being hailed
as martyrs in some quarters a lot of
reasonable americans looking at it and
saying oh my gosh like dozens of people
died
you can see the you can imagine the
images on social media that would be
playing
uh day day and night well you don't i
mean like january 6 happened those guys
are in a prison in washington and they
sing the national anthem every night
because they consider themselves
political prisoners
right like they consider themselves
political prisoners um they
and many do as well so the first thing
in the book that i assumed which january
6 i think showed pretty clearly and you
wrote this book before january 6th oh
yeah when the book when the january 6
happens you're like oh wow i had to
throw in a chapter i just wrote a
chapter right like i'd already written
that but it just happened so i had to
it's no longer a prediction um so i had
to throw it a chapter but you know what
happened was like immediately within
hours the media narrative diverged right
like within hours uh you have rush
limbaugh saying i i'm glad the men at
concord used guns when they had to and
i'm glad that they they weren't opposed
to revolution and then you have the left
being like this is an assault on
democracy it immediately bifurcates into
these media networks the political
people respond to that automatically i
mean you know january 6th is horrible
but january 6 happens to a lot of
countries right like we had to declare
martial law in 1970 in canada uh you're
all european countries have had similar
this is not something unknown to history
but what is really shocking to me was
the members of congress not showing up
to
give a minute of silence for the
uh to for the police officer who was
slain on congress defending their
physical security like that like
literally fighting for their lives and
dying and they can't they do not have
the
collective narrative sensibility to get
together to mourn this man so that
that's that's the level of the the
narrative divide right where like it
just splits then of course in the in the
book you have a question of well the
military
is really in an impossible position uh
not
tactically like
like
the marines are
nobody can go up against the marines the
marines are tough they are not losing to
anyone never mind a bunch of militiamen
who like are with ar-15s and so on like
they they would i i tried to i talked to
many military experts and i was like
well give me a battle scene like give me
a scene where there's engagement they
were like there's no engagement we just
walk over them if i walk over them you
mean kill them yeah like like in terms
of an engagement like it's an nba team
against your local sunday night pickup
game it is
professionals with every
attribute in their side technological in
like they just want there's no there's
no there's nothing to describe like
that's what they told me so but that
doesn't really matter because america
has learned about counter insurgency
through 70 years of failure like there's
no like when you win you still lose
right and the the legal nightmare of
trying to
wage war against people who are your
fellow citizens especially in america um
because of the because of the nature of
the constitution
if you were to have u.s citizens killed
on american soil by the armed forces uh
it would be
a nightmare and it would inflame tens of
millions of americans exactly very very
directly yeah and i mean
given that you know even an assault on
the capital gets split into factions
really quickly like imagine what that
would do well i mean i did imagine it
it's
i mean the problem with counter
insurgency that they learned over and
over again is that the attempts to stop
violence
inflame inflamed violence over and over
again right and it's certainly i i have
no reason to think that would not happen
in the united states which is a you know
with intense concepts of freedom really
messianic impossible concepts of freedom
uh you know in this in this in this
space
one thing you mentioned is that there
are many elements of the armed forces
that are kind of aligned with
conservative belief uh and some of these
are sympathetic to some of the the far
right groups that it's not like if you
lined up the armed forces they're
evenly split between different political
ideologies uh and and i know there are
different people that are concerned at
various levels that
you would have a split among the armed
forces themselves you might have certain
armed forces members who want to sit it
out
or who have no interest in taking arms
against
uh their fellow americans who they feel
are standing up for what is right
well no one knows how any military would
react but um
i mean i would say like for example in
arkansas in the 50s when they had to
send in the military and they this
that's still other than 1992 the l.a
riots that's still the
foremost legal example of sending in u.s
troops to into the u.s um you know they
did order arkansas soldiers to barracks
right like they they did not use them in
the field i mean you know we we have a
pretty good sense of the infiltration of
uh hard right militias into police
forces which is quite extensive and
hugely troubling but you know the stuff
about the military is much weaker like
that that's not like they don't there
there's no um you know there's the
military times asked people have you
seen white power insignia and there was
a huge number of people who said that
and there are other evidence that
there's obviously white power
things in in the military but we don't
know how extensive they are the other
thing is that the you the military oath
um
unlike virtually every other us
institution uh has
held up incredibly well um like i think
that like if that goes if the military
oath goes and they don't follow command
um the country really is over like uh
you know like that that's that's the end
but i i actually don't think that will
fall um i think the chain of command is
so is so strong and the understanding of
the oath in the military is
at least from the people that i talked
to it's and also you know you could see
this during the trump years where even
pro-trump generals and so on were
you know basically not going to have any
part of this nonsense um
like that's
i'm less worried about the military than
i am about police forces if i can put it
that way
interestingly enough
americans trust the military more they
trust about just about any other
institution you know like at this point
it's not like oh we love our political
leaders and it's like oh then the
military is lower on the totem pole
actually the military's at the top of
the food chain in terms of
uh american trust
the military's very worried about it i
mean like the senior people i spoke to
talked about a monopoly of trust that's
not what the military's supposed to do
military is a tool that civilian people
are supposed to use and that like they
they are not intended to be political
um animals they're not intended to solve
internal political they're the worst
possible people
and they know it they're absolutely
conscious of that right like the the
military does not exist to
dictate anything about civilian power
structures in fact it requires really
strong civilian power structures to
function
to do its basic functions so i mean
they're openly talking about what
what what horrible position they're
being increasingly being put in um
because like they yeah they are they are
the only
national institution that really has
massive amounts of trust from the
american people and that's that alone is
a very very dangerous fact now military
too like that's the that's the least
likely scenario for america for me um
like i think that's really marginal like
it's not i mean nothing's impossible in
this world but that's that's really
highly unlikely because you have this
military professional culture that makes
them unlikely to try and use their
political control
they for i mean what they don't want the
power for one thing but also you know
the number one dr the number one
predictor of uh coup is that you you
have a history of twos and america has
no history of goose right it has a
history of assassination that's
extensive it has a you know lengthy
history of political violence it has
history of occupation it has a history
of civil war but it there there are not
coups right this is the longest this is
the most enduring democracy ever right
um so
you know that that seems to me uh pretty
pretty unlikely
[Music]
your
book also includes a scenario around a
president being assassinated and there
was a statistic that blew my mind that
said something like one out of every 11
presidents has been assassinated and
that yeah assassination is something
of a pattern in american life
should have told me that before i ran
for president stephen
well i'm sure they told you right after
right i mean you know like i'm sure like
the the guys that came to protect you
did you you i mean
what was that like did you get did you
have your own security or did they come
to you
uh so the way it works in politics is
that you get secret service protection
after you become the nominee of a major
party which i never did
right
so i fell short of getting secret
service details
um right there were various threats
against me at different times and
different law enforcement people
uh were notified um so so there there
was some interaction with law
enforcement trying to to
make sure i was safe so some people just
didn't like the idea of everyone having
money we're like oh that free money guy
get him
well i mean i have to say like
i had a friend who ran for alderwoman in
hudson valley and she got death threats
right like i mean
increasingly death threats are for like
certainly as a journalist like you don't
know how many have i gotten after
publishing this book at least half a
dozen right i mean like i mean obviously
it's much more serious for you it's like
it's a real possibility but but uh but
you know the normalization of of threats
it's one reason why a lot of republican
members of congress were reluctant to
impeach trump uh or right to uh to have
a commission around january 6th because
um they got death threats and they you
know they looked at it and said you know
what like is this that important to me
is democracy that important i mean my i
have so little sympathy for that i must
say i mean
like you
because when they they go to their you
know town hall or their airport or
whatever and then they they have a crazy
person screaming at them and whatnot um
like and you know threatening their
family they get like you know their
dozen death threats like a a lot of
these members of congress uh are not
properly protected in my opinion they
have nothing they have nothing close to
what you'd imagine as secret service
protection and and so they they back
down um i don't think it's right
um right but i suppose i'm more
sympathetic
maybe because
um i know some of the people involved
who've either
put up through it and walked through it
and seen all of the
fire they had to walk through i mean it
just did not seem easy i i get that like
i i truly understand what you're talking
about but like you know my grandfather
like had to fly in a back of a bomber
and drop bombs over hamburg for
democracy like like the democracy has
always required
quite a bit of sacrifice from from
people like it like it it seems like
and the stakes now the stakes are real
the stakes are democracy in america
right that's what that is what is at
play
i'm imagining what they're talking
themselves into it's like look these are
my constituents this is the way they
feel i'm elected to represent them and
if they they think that this was a
legitimate political expression uh and
not and yeah i mean i like i'm just
imagining that that some of the
the i mean kind of wait and get a
regular job is that that that's not the
hardest thing in the world to me like
that's not an unwarranted sacrifice for
like like uh you do have a ton of people
retiring i think the last number i saw
you you know you have
at this point i believe over 20 members
of congress who are saying i'm out and
some of it is because of what we're
talking about right now
and i also don't know
who we're considering running for office
who are like i'm not going to run for
office given the madness
right yeah and i mean that's part of the
breakdown right i mean when i talked
about the complex cascading system like
it is exact that that's why crazy things
keep happening because it's like well
the violence leads to it's not
necessarily what you see it's what you
don't see it's like the people who don't
run the people who don't enter politics
the and then that beca and then that
feeds into bad decision-making which
leads to worse outcomes which leads to
more insanity right like that's how
that's that that's how this feedback
loop kind of works right and it's yeah
it's like it's broken
your book did make me think that that
we've gone uh a while without an
assassination
well secret service are amazing like i
would not uh
like
it would be it would be a total fluke if
there were to be a presidential
assassination i mean a lot of things
would have to go wrong now
a lot of things do go wrong like you
know like as a in the book it's not hard
to imagine how it would happen but you
know the secret service are uh
the best like they are extremely
extremely good at what they do i think
like a like a a group like if if if a
militia decided to send out an assassin
to kill the president they wouldn't have
a chance in my opinion like they they
would have they would they would they
would not be able to do that it'd be
more like stochastic terrorism which is
you know increasingly what they face and
what they can't control at all because
it's just rage it's just random
internet generated rage and and that
that radicalizes itself and finds its
own methods and that that's of course
who can predict that
yeah and that's the scenario you play
out in the book where there is
an unlikely
uh series of events but if you have a
multitude of people big enough then the
unlikely event actually becomes much
more
uh plausible and possible if you had
like you're describing
millions of americans who'd been
radicalized or enraged in a particular
way
another
scenario you play out in the book is
climate change
and its effect on both
our ability to sustain cities like the
city i'm sitting in right now in new
york city
and uh yeah
and crop yields and a bunch of other
things
and you played it out over a series of
years
but that was very scary stuff i couldn't
sleep often when i was writing that
yeah and and it seemed unfortunately
uh very very
real and almost upon us
i mean those are definitely you know i i
use the best available models for
everything in this book so but some are
stronger than others right like economic
models are incredibly weak like they
just don't they don't they don't hold up
and they don't they don't have
falsifiability and they don't have a
great track record the environmental
models are basically not pretty good
they're they're they they are
unbelievably reliable um and then if you
know and then so the guy i'm talking to
about new york like he's a reinsurer
he's like a he's like a he's like a the
lead thinker of a reinsurance company
trillion dollar bets are made are placed
on his opinion of this stuff right and
um
and you know you know they're good if
people are betting
hundreds of billions of dollars on the
veracity of the model
yeah and i mean like you know there are
two reinsurance events that they can't
really reinsure for one is massive
hurricanes hitting new york and the
other is a true devastation of tokyo
right like like like those are the ones
where the size of the devastation
there's no you can't hedge out like you
can't you can't you essentially can't uh
there's nowhere to there's no market big
enough to bet against that yeah i mean
it's very very terrifying because new
york unlike like you know miami is a
great town and
houston's a great town like but new york
is new york right like it is the center
of the world and it has 88 of the
world's foreign currency transactions
take place through it and
information it is the the hub of global
information networks at least for the
west and you know it it's extremely
vulnerable um trump like the trump
administration canceled the c-ball
uh which i find shocking
um like not a lot of things shocked me
in this and then and so and so yeah and
then the other guy was the um the guy
about corn
at the usda and like you know just a
nice guy who wants to talk about corn
and it's so scary like it's so scary
talking to that guy about the future of
food because
you know our entire civilization is
based on the cheap abundant staple crops
produced by the midwest and the
incredible innovative capacity of the
american farmer which is astonishing and
they they're entering an innovation trap
where they effectively don't know what
to innovate to
and so and and that that's it's and they
don't know how to they the the moisture
variability is fluctuating in such a way
that they can't they can't plan like
they're they're brilliant at planning
but they can't really plan around these
high levels of variability at different
stages of the of the season
so
yeah the thinking about what it what
would life would be like if food were no
longer cheap really really really
frightening
it was scary stuff uh
[Music]
one of the
things that i found most helpful about
this book is you did something i'd never
seen before which is you defined civil
war
according to i believe the oslo
uh peace institute's definition which
was a thousand people dying per year
of political violence yeah combatant
death
combatant debts
and right now
america uh has something like 25 to 50
such deaths
um on an annual basis which would
qualify us as uh what what was the the
term it was like civil strife so civil
strife uh is already here in the us
and civil war would be if that went up
something like 20 to 40 times is that
correct yeah i mean you know these
definitions are like i'm trying to like
these are the best definitions i could
find i'm not like i'm not 100 it's the
best definition i've seen man because
like you see hyperbole around this all
the time you're like oh yeah civil war i
mean i i've used it myself i've been
like is the civil war in the us a
possibility and i've been saying yes for
a while but i did not know that um what
qualifies it according to at least
uh experts is a thousand combatant
deaths in a given year
yeah i mean there are also problems with
um
defining
like what a combatant death is in this
case so like i mean first of all the us
is so heterogeneous and so enormous that
like
the question is are these definitions
super super meaningful uh i mean i think
they are in a way because they show
okay we're not at civil war yet we're at
civil strife it's these but you know
like all the numbers of combatant deaths
like those are taken from
journalists and like people at in
research institutes like
adl and southern poverty law center who
go through newspaper reports and then
define them as as political violence um
because for the police and for the fbi
that's not necessarily a meaningful
category like when jared miller
went in vegas and shot two police
officers and tight and put a note saying
the revolution has started because he's
a member of the sovereign citizen group
for the police he's just a lunatic right
and so like so it like
it's up to other people to define the
nature of political violence and that
that's why you know some people even
argue there is no political violence in
the united states well i mean that seems
impossible now i mean because we just
saw jan 6 that people died so i mean
that that has to qualify well
i mean does like it doesn't have to
qualify like you could like you could
define that in any number of ways you
know part of the part of the problem is
the f defining the line between
criminality um mental illness
and political extremism
is blurry you know at the best of times
and certainly in other countries it's
it's very it's very it's very difficult
to see but um you know i i don't i don't
think like i think the point we all know
that political violence is growing and
that you can see it and like as you say
january 6 like yeah that's that's
political violence to me um when a
sovereign citizen kills some police
officers because they don't think the
federal authority
is is legitimate that to me is political
violence even if they have a history of
mental illness um
you know but but there are different
yeah i mean you know there are different
ways of cutting it up but the point i
think really is that
it's what we were talking about before
is like people running for office feel
threatened um you know people are going
mobs are going to election officials to
intimidate them that's political
violence i mean i i just don't think
there's any there's any way around
saying that's what it is and it's
definitely on the rise
it is tough to differentiate in part
because and i've been making this case
where you have a society where a lot of
people let's say men in particular are
struggling with a loss of meaning
a loss of
purpose structure fulfillment
community
and then they fall prey to these toxic
ideologies being like hey you know why
your your life isn't going the way you
want these people or these structures
and
they become radicalized like the young
man in your book um where hugh's at home
and then he starts going down the
internet rabbit hole
and you end up finding meaning in
ideas that at least have some political
association
um a lot of it is tied together with the
disintegration of uh american men is one
of the the points i'm making and
i agree it'd be tough to kind of draw a
line between
um someone being mentally ill and
someone being criminally violent and
someone being politically motivated um
so in in my mind
uh if there is any hint of them having a
political purpose i personally would
throw them in that category um be
because i think the factors are all tied
together
yeah i mean i don't like
i i try to tease them out in the book
and separate them but they're all of a
piece right like they're all they
don't it it's it's the dismal tide as
cormac mccarthy put it like um you know
i mean i would say that
there's like i remember talking to a
central banker well you know not the
central banker but
one of the
on a banker in the united states and we
were talking about and i was like well
why doesn't this happen elsewhere like
why doesn't this happen in europe and
why does this happen in canada and so he
was like well you don't he said you
don't have an army of the dispossessed
you don't have 400 million firearms
enough for every man woman and child
yeah but you said you know there are a
lot of people in america who have
nothing like if you're in canada and you
have nothing you still have health care
and education
wait wait this this stephen this is a
good national motto or slogan
in canada
if you have nothing
you still have something come to canada
well if you see a homeless guy on the
street and there's plenty of homeless in
toronto but you know that that guy gets
all the medical care that he gets the
same medical care as you
right like that's a that's a that's a
big difference right like that's a big
difference in in in what you
and and of course it creates a different
relationship to the state completely
different relationship to solidarity in
the state right but you know i mean the
other thing is like to me
the dispossession is part of it but you
know there's this really fascinating
study out of india about
um political violence and so what
happened the number one thing for
political violence in india is when they
they did it with the visa with with with
expenditure records so as muslims the
marginalized group get more money to
spend compared to hindus that's when the
violence starts right and the the and
they this can be so everywhere
well exactly because like what's
actually happening is in america you
have you know black people and and
latino people moving up
and you have
economically politically america's about
to become a majority minority country by
2040 and as that happens that the over
class essentially reacts with violence
and you can see that everywhere you can
see that in india you can see it all
over africa you can see it in asia you
can see it in the middle east certainly
so
you know that that is to me if you're
asking what the deeper process is
underway the psychological process
that that would be right at the top of
the list in fact when there's an amazing
study that came out about the january 6
insurrectionists and they own like
only a very about 20 of them were from
the militias but the the huge
overwhelming factor was that they all
came from counties where exactly that
thing had happened where exactly that
phenomenal i saw that where they came
from counties that had been becoming
more diverse uh relatively recently and
you know it's amazing because it's not
them becoming poorer right
it's it's not like it's not like them
becoming it's not them losing it's the
people below them gaining in relation to
them that they that causes the violence
which is even worse i mean like
is even darker
yes so when you've been talking the book
and you mentioned before that a
conservative actually framed it as like
is civil war so bad which is a very very
dark reaction
what was the reaction from the left um
and so here here's at least my thinking
on it is that
when people talk about this civil war
uh
we think that the active threat is from
the far right
which by the way i agree with i mean you
know that there are a number of reasons
for this and so
i'm curious whether folks on the left
take this threat very very seriously or
are dismissive of it because they're
kind of institutionalists
yeah well i mean
you can probably speak to this i know
you can speak to this better than me
because i don't understand
why
so many like the chuck schumers of this
world and the joe bidens of this world
are not like how there was any debate
about the filibuster at all is just
totally beyond me right like it's like
this system is inco but i think it i
mean the only explanation i can come up
for their political reaction is that
they're so invested in these
institutions that they can't really they
can't really accept them collapsing and
of course you know as a foreigner when
you talk to americans they worship their
institutions they've been taught from
childhood that this is the greatest
political system in the history of the
world it's the answer to history uh you
know effectively like who was it um
the guy with the big mustache who was
the big hawk in the iraq war what was
his name
i mean he said what we should have done
as a rock is go in and throw in the
federalist papers and say figure it out
right and like and uh just the
assumption of um the superiority of the
american system above all i think it's
extremely hard to shake especially when
you're 80 right like like it's extremely
hard to shake the shake it when you've
lived your whole life
in that legacy you know in that which is
of course a very glorious legacy i mean
i i'm not denying that it isn't it just
happens to be broken right um
so you know i think that's what but you
know you could probably answer that
better than me the people on the left
that i've talked to
my experience has been they're starting
to wake up that um really basic things
like democracy are at stake and it's
probably you know things like
fighting over dave chappelle might have
to be sidelined for a while the struggle
now is clearly over
institutions and what they should look
like rather than you know the kind of uh
cultural politics um that have sort of
dominated the left for you know 10 years
now
well if there is a wake up call you're
one of the people making it um and
i think one of the things that you may
run into
um that uh i can vouch for uh is that at
this point many democrats have become
kind of the voices and the defenders of
the fading establishment and the fading
institutions and then the republicans
have been overtaken by this
anti-institutional zeal
um and when you say something like hey
you know maybe these institutions are
having problems some democrats take it
as a partisan attack which is certainly
not the intent it's like hey you know i
kind of want you to not screw up
or i want your stuff to work
or i just want american society to work
um but but unfortunately in a polarized
environment uh you know like they'll
take anything
that questions
their prized institutions uh as
something that's partisan or political
because conservatives generally will
take this narrative that you're saying
and be like oh yeah like oh yeah this is
happening exactly yeah that's right well
i mean the genre of civil war
science fiction that's all conservative
right there's a there's a vast genre of
like imagine civil wars like texas
separating and sending f-15s to bomb you
know oklahoma like there's there's like
a whole genre of that all conservative
right um like but i think the left like
because i think because it's starting to
steer them right in the face you know
like
biden could not get his diplomats
you know nominated for a year
right like these are basic tasks of
government right
very basic tasks of government like
guaranteeing your debt like they're
playing they're playing really dangerous
games with with with national debt
that makes no sense to anyone else
this is totally just bizarre it's like
it's like why on earth would you do that
uh like
but also like well as we said before
there was no nobody showed up at the
usda like nobody was minding the store
that's what scared me
most americans have no idea that that
happened or didn't happen right well but
i think like it's pretty clear it isn't
working right like you know like amen
increa and you know and and i think
increasingly when you
like one of the things is that like
americans barely even talk about policy
anymore right because like to talk about
policy would be
to imply that you have a government that
could enact a policy and
i that there is no government that can
enact a policy so instead there's make
america great again or socialism right
which is which you know
the meaning of socialism when it comes
out of an american politician's mouth is
unrelated to what socialism means
anywhere else in the world
i know what you're talking about
like completely well i remember because
the 2015 canadian election had ended and
i
and i went to a trump sanders rally for
the guardian right to report the next
day
and i left canada and the canadian
elections are like
sir we need to spend 26.8 million
dollars on education
no you're completely wrong we need to
increase that budget to 32.8 million
it's all numbers and boring and nobody
watches and it's just totally banal and
boring because it's all policy it's all
like actual debates around policies
right that's my kind of debate
you feel right i should move to canada
the forward party in canada see how it
goes you know um but
like you go to america and it's like god
and socialism
and then there's no numbers no one
brings up any numbers because
you know it would be it would actually
be meaningless to talk about numbers you
know because what like look at biden he
controls the senate and
the house and he still can't pass you
know what in effect is a budget
right so like i i think people are
starting to figure out that like the
americans entered a post-policy phase
essentially
uh it has become ungovernable and that's
that's unsustainable
well uh enjoyed your book a great deal i
think it's important that people
understand that you can be talking about
these matters like the next civil war
and do it not from a conservative or
a liberal perspective but just from a
perspective of fact
reason
data and study uh again i appreciate
your work love the book um and thank you
so much steven for writing it and for
sounding the alarm
always great to talk to andrew
[Music]
you